excusez moi pour le blanc c'est des
perfectionnistes des micros donc
j'espère vraiment on y vient je suis
éducateur spécialisé éducateur de rue
pour être plus exact dans un centre de
soins pour toxicomanes
bien sûr bordeaux je travaille depuis
dix ans maintenant on travaille même si
l'on est interdite en binôme avec ma
collègue agnès auprès de jeunes en
errance public spécifique on a mis en
place plusieurs actions spécifiques
aussi pour aller au plus près de ce
public pour aller dans les squats pour
travailler en travail de rue pour
travailler en festivals pour essayer
d'aller au plus près de de la difficulté
des publics qui ne viennent pas vers nos
centres de soins j'aurais l'appeler
commandes/stocks les jeunes en errance
qu'est ce que ça veut dire merci à
jeûner en errance que ça veut dire
peut-être que tout simplement vous êtes
promenés dans des rues piétonnes et vous
avez rencontrées vous aussi ce qu'on
appelle classiquement les punks à chiens
en coin de rue sainte catherine ou
autres qui font la manche
je n'en pensais pas que ça mais c'est
aussi ça c'est aussi cette cette errance
qui donne à voir qui donne à voir sa
misère qui donne à voir ces difficultés
il ya aussi tout un autre type d'errance
beaucoup plus diffuse beaucoup plus
caché avec des handicaps plus cacher
aussi et nous on prend en charge
l'ensemble de ces difficultés l'ensemble
de ces jeunes et on essaie au quotidien
d'aller travailler auprès de ce public
je pense que pour qu'on soit d'accord on
va mettre en place une définition
ensemble je pense que là le plus petit
dénominateur commun tous ces jeunes là
tout type dénominateur commun à
l'errance c'est peut-être le fait qu'ils
ont mis à distance
une situation insupportable on va
s'entendre là-dessus
et donc du coup il met à distance la
figure adultes
du coup il met à distance notre société
ils reconstruisent une famille de rue et
reconstruisent des liens de rue évident
d entre eux soit en squattant
communautaires tout ce qu'on a pu
croiser le coin de la rue
sainte-catherine comme on disait
précédemment
on m'a demandé de vous parler d'un
projet d'un dispositif qu'on a mis en
place s'appelle tapage travail
alternatif à la manche payés à la
journée
alternatif à la manche parce que je
défie quiconque d'entre vous d'avoir les
compétences qu'on ces jeunes là pour
pouvoir sortir 40 euros dont ils ont
besoin pour vivre et leurs animaux de
compagnie dans la journée la rue c'est
un vrai travail c'est de vraies
compétences pour connaître la bonne
géographie pour connaître le bon temps
pour connaître les bonne accroche pour
pouvoir aller voir le public et pour
pouvoir faire au mieux cette manche qui
leur permet de vivre parce qu'entre 18
et 25 ans ils ont aucune autre moyen de
survivants a par là même la manche où
les petits larcins travail alternatif à
la manche il ya la journée tapage c'est
quoi c'est tout simple tapage c'est
l'idée qu'on mettait en échec en
difficulté des jeunes pendant des années
en mettant sur des dispositifs
spécifiques qui ne convenait pas du tout
alors leur vision du monde du travail à
leur capacité à s investir pendant 20 ou
25 heures par semaine
en clair les échecs consécutifs qu'on a
pu avoir en les mettant sur des
chantiers d'insertion pour partie du
chantier d'insertion marche très bien je
jette pas l'opprobre sur ce dispositif
là sauf que au final pour ces jeunes là
on l'aimé ans aux précarités quand on ne
pense pas du tout aux animaux de
compagnie et ses animaux de compagnie là
ils sont à la charge pendant un mois de
l'ensemble du squat
quand on pense pas du tout que l'on met
à mal leurs horaires de manche et donc
du coup qui n'ont plus la capacité de
subvenir pour payer les progrès de
l'animal de compagnie pour pour subvenir
aux besoins de l'ensemble du squat et
donc on sur précarisant payant en fin de
mois aussi
ces jeunes là le fait qu'ils doivent
être dépendant des autres jeunes qui
vont faire la manche pendant
l'ensemble du mois enfin bref je
voudrais ça rapidement le décor vous
commencez à comprendre que on participe
aussi de cette précarisation et de la
façon dont on est en difficulté ce
public là est donc cette idée géniale
moi j'ai juste la chance d'aller me
balader au québec parce que les petits
15 ans j'ai les pieds des deux côtés de
l'atlantique
professionnellement et familialement
aussi et donc du coup j'ai eu la chance
de croiser cette idée géniale là-bas et
de la ramener dans les bagages en 2007
en 2014 ça fait trois ans que ça existe
a donc la vie en face juste un long
fleuve tranquille
effectivement tapage la première fois
qu'on en a parlé comme on en compte
entre la présenter pour faire bref et
rapide on s'est fait tirer dessus à
boulet rouge pour les plus gentils on
nous a dit que c'était la crise qui
commençait à arriver que l'aller falloir
regarder un peu les budgets que c'était
pas si simple que ça dans le social et
pour les plus désagréables c'était aussi
nous dire qu on détruisait le code du
travail qu'on était des suppôts du medef
et que ont participé à travailler avec
tous ces gens-là tapage c'est pas ça du
tout tapage c'est l'idée tout simplement
de créer des marchepieds successifs pour
aller aider ces jeunes là à se
remobiliser et à allait repartir vers
une motivation a essayé de se remettre
sur les marchés du travail c'est lé
dispositif de revalorisation c'est pas
du tout on n'a pas la prétention de
faire de l'insertion professionnelle
c'est vraiment de la revalorisation pour
eux on sait tous à quel point la rue
peut abîmer la rue peut exposer les
temporalités tapage c'est juste un jeune
qui vient avec une demande d'assistanat
pour lequel on répond avec une
possibilité travail le jour même ou le
lendemain en me disant viens tu as
besoin de l'assistance
d'habitude on s'est tu répondras et
d'assistance là tu vas venir travailler
avec nous je vous rendent pas dans les
détails de la de la popote qu'on a pu
mettre en place ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'on a voulu marquer les codes du
travail des livres dès les premières
heures c'est à dire qu'il a un vrai
contrat de travail qui cotisent pour de
vrai et qu'on va pas être le bon
éducateur des années 70 qui tape sur
l'épaule qui ouvre la boîte au quality
street et qui va donner l'argent liquide
répondu en disant c'est bien tu as bien
travaillé mon gêne non on est sur les
et code du travail du coup ce jeune là
on va un chèque à la fin de la journée
sauf que ce chèque là il a faim de
magique qu'on respecte c'est son
parcours d'errance et que si ce soir il
prend son sac à dos pour partir à
marseille de manhattan et dans n'importe
quel guichet de poste et à marcher il
aura les changes en liquide de delà même
de la monnaie keane qui présente sur le
chèque tapage c'est ça ta page c'est
aussi une histoire de rencontres parce
que je crois fondamentalement que la vie
est une histoire de rencontre et si on
m'avait si j'avais juste écouter les
gens qui nous ont répondu ça au début si
j'avais pas aussi écouter autour de moi
y avait des gens qui croyaient à ce
projet là et qui qui dans une mairie qui
dans une fondation qui dans une eau à
fond de dotation qui est au sein même de
mon association voulait continuer à
croire à ce projet et à le construire on
n'aurait pas pu aller plus loin tapage
c'est l'idée de se dire que l'on à lire
repenser entièrement un modèle
économique qui le modèle classique en
france ont fait un budget prévisionnel
sur un an et les chaussons de fiabiliser
et enfin il faut remettre en place les
choses et qu on allait se donner la
possibilité de lancer avec des minimums
de fond la possibilité de mettre en
place avec des jeunes des travaux parce
qu'une mairie croit en nous et nous dit
de toute façon on est submergé de mon
réserve dans notre ville et que quand le
fasse ou non sa nana on a peur on peut
pas vous demander des exigences de
rendement parce que de toute façon les
choses sont beaucoup trop compliqué et
donc on fait confiance à ces jeunes là
on n'est pas sur des travaux travaux à
bessan on est sur des travaux qui vont
les valoriser et passer un regard sur
eux qui est valorisé et des jeunes qui
vont pouvoir communiquer et exprimer un
peu ce qu'ils peuvent faire de manière
un fier c'est cette jeune avec un
éducateur qui travaillent qui
travaillent dans les rues de bordeaux
actuellement
et puis dans une seconde phase tapage
ses possibilités dire à ces jeunes ne
travaillent c'est pas con qu'un rapport
financier un travail aussi cinq groupes
humains une rencontre humaine avec
laquelle on s'épanouit
on se découvre mais qui nous impose
aussi des dés de voir un groupe humain
avec lequel on doit être obligés de
de pouvoir elles sont une présentation
de soi qui est à peu près la même d'un
jour sur l'autre et c'est ça qu'on va
interroger sur la face de cette
possibilité pour un jeune de pouvoir
expérimenter à venir deux jours trois
jours quatre jours d'affilée
pas forcément plus en nombre d'heures
mais pouvoir essayer d'être sur une
qualité de présentation de lui à peu
près similaire d'un jour sur l'autre
pour pouvoir se mobiliser et se prouver
qu'il est capable de rentrer dans un
dispositif classique d'insertion ou
alors dans un dans un contrat de droit
commun ça c'est des chantiers qui ont
été faits avec d'autres partenaires ou
des jeunes cessé sur trois quatre jours
d'affilée mais ne supporte pas l'idée
d'être encore en intérieur et vont être
sûr d aménagement des espaces verts
c'est pas rien 113 mètres cubes de
déchets cd je commence quand même à
pousser un peu on n'est pas juste
l'arrachage de la petite brindille est
là après on est avec d'autres types de
partenaires qui vont nous demander des
missions avec des jeunes sur du travail
plus individuelle le modèle éducatif
qu'on a mis en place modélisme modèle
économique on a mis en place juneau
justement nous permet d'avoir une
liberté éducative avec ces jeunes là
c'est un archipel de financement
différencié
c'est un archipel de financement avec de
gros groupes nationaux et une mairie qui
nous permet d'avoir avec chacun d'eux
des chantiers tas de travail différent
on a actuellement avec le groupe auchan
la groupe sncf
erdf le groupe orange et la mairie de
bordeaux
différents types de chantiers qui nous
permet justement d'avoir une liberté
dans l'accompagnement éducatif et de
pouvoir répondre au mieux adapter au
mieux avec ces jeunes-là
l'accompagnement qu'on souhaite faire
hélas comme vous voyez la chasuble et
c'est plus une chasuble tapas chaîne sa
double au champ c'est la fierté qu'on a
d'avoir actuellement et ça c'est pas
nous qui disons c'est la direccte les
sorties positives à plus de 50% qui
explose complètement le lait les quotas
de l'insertion classique avec des jeunes
qui sont embauchés soit par des soit par
le groupe auchan soit par le groupe sncf
actuellement et des jeunes qui vont
expérimenter à d'autres types de métiers
comme les le rapport à l'art ou le
rapport au numérique actuellement je
tape h ça intéressait ministère qui a
décidé d'en faire un et smash sur la
france entière on a actuellement dix
villes en france qui aime qui fait
développer le dispositif
voilà j'ai été très sommaire j'espère
vous avez à peu près compris l'évolution
des choses et la façon dont on marche la
page tout ça n'a pas grande importance
tapage est un outil parmi d'autres c'est
un bon outil un bel outil j'y crois plus
que tout je crois tellement que
j'accompagne l'esma joue au niveau
français sur les sols et 10 autres
villes
si on revient un peu si on rembobine à
ce que je vous disais au départ tapage
c'est juste un outil parmi d'autres pour
essayer de se mettre en lien avec ces
jeunes qui se mettent à la marche de
notre société qui met à distance de
cette figure adultes qui trouve
totalement insupportable et donc du coup
pas page pour nous c'est cette volonté
de pouvoir aller faire des ponts avec
ces jeunes là lui montrer que dans
toutes ces difficultés dans tout ce
temps de galère qu'il est en train de
vivre il est aussi en train de mettre à
distance une adolescence par l'extrême
qu'il est en train de vivre et que d'un
moment où à un moment ou un autre il
allait falloir qu'ils ce qu'ils pensent
et figura dutil sud radio qui est un
qu'il est qui va qui va être lui aussi
est donc pour nous l'idée principale de
tout ça que ce soit ce dispositif ou
d'autres c'est bien l'idée de se dire
qu'on va filer du bien qu'on va être en
train de constamment ramener ces jeunes
verts vers une possibilité de se
construire de se structurer pas
forcément de s'insérer socialement
peut-être qu'on veut la voir avec un
contre 1 35 heures même si ça peut être
de manière alternative vote n'a que peu
d'importance pour nous mais en tout cas
qui puisse voir en nouant d'autres une
des figures adultes acceptable qui lui
permettent de se dire que lui aussi un
jour il a envie d'
de passer le pas et d'écrire sa propre
vie tapage c'est avant tout sa fille les
du lien c'est avant tout ça pour nous
comme comme raison et comme motivation
au quotidien et si par ce message là
j'ai pu vous donner à vous aussi envie
de filer certains liens et mais
certaines rencontrent au quotidien de
votre vie merci de nous avoir écoutés